if you have any questions during the
presentation so she don't mind your
question interrupting her well I'll turn
the time over to Sofia
hi everyone
and get down from introduction and thank
you so much everyone for coming today
we're going to talk about Anaconda
notebooks if you are in the right room
yay
uh so before we get started I want you
to talk a little bit about myself my
name is Sophia young I am a data
scientist and a developer Advocate and
Anaconda I've been working and Anaconda
for more than four years almost five
years now and I am a big fan of the open
source High data ecosystem and I have
contributed to some open source packages
and have a great head and some open
source packages I also volunteer at
non-focus in various Pi data and sci-fi
conferences
oh yeah my background is saying
psychology statistics and computer
science
if you have any questions please let me
know I know my background is kind of
interesting
so agenda for today we're going to talk
about what is Anaconda hopefully you all
know what is Anaconda and then the
second half we're going to talk about
the focus of the talk today is not
Anaconda notebooks I'm going to do a
live demo on Anaconda notebooks
hopefully it would work uh from your
cross because sometimes demo you know
but hopefully today would work
so we'll just save the conda how many of
you have used Anaconda
so much
uh you are our users
so we have more than 35 near me and
users across the globe
across
231 countries and regions so everywhere
where everywhere everyone uses us most
of the fortune companies Fortune 500
companies use us as well we
so at Anaconda we have 7.1 billion
package downloads and we also founded Pi
data which is the largest largest data
science organ in the world so including
this conference
our co-founder Travelers and Peter uh
co-founded non-focus which then funded
hi David
yeah so
Anaconda is a one platform Powers all
data science and data analytics work at
the foundation of my operating Anaconda
is that we're open source uh software
Community most of you probably know or
don't know that at Anaconda we have a
big open source board with support many
of the open source packages including
Jupiter number of High Spirit Halloween
and many others we also donate a lot of
money to non-focus every year
which is a lot of money so if you are a
anaconda customer you contribute to your
anaconda part of our Revenue actually
goes towards non-focus and contribute to
the other open source libraries that we
are not directly contributing
and then on top of the open source
software Community we build our packages
and environment that you are probably
most familiar with including an economic
installers and our conduct package
environment
we help practitioners to develop and
train machine learning models analyze
data visualized results we also help
practitioners to deploy our models with
with one-click deployment with our
anacond notebooks and also our data
science platforms
and we also secure your python supply
chain a lot of us uh a lot of the data
scientists and data analysts probably
don't realize that security is a big
issue in the python ecosystem and it
admins really care about this we need to
make sure the packages you use are
secure there are actually a lot of
vulnerabilities in your python packages
and an economics sure you you uh scan
all your packages and only install the
secure packages
here's another view of all all of our
feature offerings we have packages and
environments with thousands of Open
Source packages we support development
within a kind of notebooks in account
learning which is our new learning
platform that was launched this year we
also have deployment features with one
click deployment and job scheduler and
then finally like I mentioned we provide
security and governance for your I.T
admins and your it managers to make sure
your package is secured and Appliance
okay so today we're going to talk about
Anaconda notebooks
so how many of you have no Anaconda
books or know about have used Anaconda
books
awesome yay so in account notebooks it's
not the cheaper notebooks you're
thinking about so I'll talk about in a
second it's actually uh our Cloud
notebook offering you can use Anaconda
notes on the cloud without need to
install or configure anything
to use that go to in account.cloud and
click notebooks and you can get started
coding right away okay now let me show
you some demos
so
oh I guess before I show you the demos
only here's the outline of whether we're
going to talk about today I'm going to
talk go through some of the basics of an
account notebooks I'm going to talk
about environment management data
catalogs of how to use the pre-populated
data set that we have included in
notebooks and also a few exciting
features that are coming soon one is app
deployment another one is Anaconda
assistant with the power of llms that's
pretty popular nowadays
okay so let's get started to
anaconda.cloud
so in account.cloud is a place where you
learn and code right we have a lot of
content right here we have a lot of
webinars uh blog posts you can also find
our python introductory courses and
machine learning courses all Anaconda
learning uh and then if you go click to
an account notebooks it will direct
direct you to our Anaconda notebooks
does it look familiar to you if you're
familiar with the Jupiter lab this is
exactly looks looks like Jupiter lab
right okay so it just looks and feels
like Jupiter Labs so we can start coding
right now if you open up a Jupiter
notebook a notebook right here in
Jupiter lab you can start coding for
example import pandas as PD right you
can print
hello world
cool so one thing I want to mention
about Anaconda notebooks is that you
actually don't need to configure
anything or install any packages to get
started using uh we provide a default
kernel for you which which includes
python39 and all the 300 plus packages
that you would normally get when you
download
installers so a lot of the packages are
data scientists use are already included
in the Anaconda box environment so you
can just get started coding without
needs you trying to figure out the
environment issues
uh okay so
either way I thought I forgot to mention
any kind of notebooks is completely free
you will get free uh 10 megabytes of
storage and unlimited of CPU usage time
when you get started using NFL notebooks
but if you want to upgrade to having
more just disk usage and CPU usage we
have a a
conference code for you hi Seattle
whatever which year you know that'll be
as well that you can have free upgrade
for your NFL notebooks but for most of
the things if you don't do crazy machine
learning ignoring stuff uh the free
version should be enough for your G4
okay
so that's that so I want to show you if
you would like to configure your
environment and manage your your
environment what can you do with any
kind of notebooks so we have a readme
file here that comes with Anaconda
notebooks
and we have a session called Panda
environment this is how you would use
an environment in in kind of notebooks
it looks exactly the same as your normal
Honda environment management environment
management management
Command right if you turn the
environment list to list all of your
environments
now you can see we're at the facing
Ramen that is provided for you is
Anaconda python39 and I also created
three other enrollments with Python 3
310 and python 311
and another testing moment that I that
I've named and then if you do contact
list it will list all the environments
that's included in your current
environment
not going to run this right now
bringing it and then if you want to
create a custom environment you can use
content create that's just name to give
your new environment a name and then you
can you can Define your python versions
of the environment you want to create
one thing that's different with Anaconda
notebooks is that you need to include
this iPad kernel package
to make sure you download this package
so that you can use in accountable so
that's the only thing different within
accountant notebooks and the regular
contact commands
okay and then you can install packages
like your regular contact store type
name for example pandas pandas is
already included in the base environment
or we don't need to install pandas but
if you're watching store something else
it could do that
and then to change your kernel or your
environment you can select your
preferred environment whether it is
python 310 python or python39 or just
use their AC environment
uh
and if you don't watch you do your
environment environment Management in
your notebook interface you can do
everything in the terminal as well
for example conda and list it will show
you all the environments you have
so that's environment management
any questions so far
we're all good
okay the next thing I want to show you
is Anaconda data catalogs
so at intercon notebooks we provide
a bunch of data catalogs for you to play
with and we will keep adding data
catalogs for you and we'll soon release
a interface for you to upload your data
to Anaconda notebooks as well
so let's take a look at our data loop
catalogs to see what it means
so when you click on each of the data
the tiles here you'll get a hero
notebook so even if we don't have any
Python Programming links the programming
skills or experience you can just click
on our hero notebooks and get started
coding
uh so let me show you what does it work
how does it work so here I'm using let
me try another one here yes
so share a notebook we just given a name
called hero notebook because when you
click on each tile it will populate a
notebook for you which is called those
notebooks here on Notebook for you to
play with
it's like a template or a starting point
for you to start coding
yeah thank you
um yeah so here we have a U.S wind
turbine data set uh and here's the hero
notebooks of the wind turbine data set
so we first import our Anaconda
catalogs and then we load the catalog
in a second
and now I can see the data for the wind
turbine
data set as a data as a pandas data
frame and they can start playing
okay so how do we do that
uh sorry
okay
I forgot
anyways so intake catalog I want to
show you what intake is so our Anaconda
catalog is filled on top of the intake
catalog so imagine if you're a data
scientist right I just want to play with
a panda State offering I don't care
about which is the source uh where my
data is from I mean I might care about
where they're from but I just want them
to load up on my Jupiter notebook and I
don't really care about their format
whether they're CSV or parquet or Json
file right I just want them to be able
to for me to quite easily in my Egyptian
notebook
data catalog it provides an interface
okay here we go it provides the
interface for you to load your catalog
uh using a consistent
way of loading your data consistently
for example you open your anaconda
catalog and
quote examples dot your data a specific
data name right so it's the same thing
as if your if your data is on stripe if
your data is um Salesforce I created the
intake Salesforce driver right you just
do intake open Salesforce data and with
a specific data set in the Salesforce
data sets and then you can load the data
as consistently using the same command
so the way it works is that it's
actually a yaml file defining your
intake drivers you're trying to use if
you want to load a CSV file you are
using a intake CSV driver
and then you're actually
not storing the file anywhere you're
using an existing file either on your
GitHub page or you are on your S3 bucket
or on your
um your Salesforce instance for example
right so we finish this data when we
call Intake open catalog and get this
data
um
yeah so that's how intake works and if
we want to
plot this data right because in the Json
file we also Define some of the plugin
options you can explore your data if you
want to share this catalog with other
people and you want to show this plot
really easily you can define a plot here
you can take a look at the plot
okay great so this is a plot
that we predefined in the case into
catalog and
there should be
okay that's fine
uh any questions so far with intake
catalogs
okay cool
um yeah so here's the hero notebook that
we just mentioned that you can load on
load different data sets into your
Jupiter notebook super easily and
consistently with intake catalog and
with Anaconda catalog service
and once you have loading your data you
can visualize your data pretty easily
using the plot functions
so the next exciting thing I want to
talk to you about is our upcoming
feature which is app deployment
yay it was exciting and excited about
this feature so with Anaconda notebooks
you can click on one button and get this
dashboard or any dashboard you're making
or any app you're making uh so let's
just go through this dashboard really
quickly this is again the wind turbine
data where we visualize the
get a plot with all the locations of
wind turbines in the US and this table
will show you all the wind turbines
that's in the data set and we have
different views this is actually a visit
chart if you have gone to the zoo uh
workshop two days ago you might be
fascinated about how easy to do
stereotyping with a busy so
demo a little bit on this notebook
you can zoom in and it actually renders
every time you zoom it's actually using
data Shader
um at the back end to support this
zooming so it's really fast when you do
so
this dashboard is actually called a
panel dashboard panel data Shader
actually plot are all packages within
the whole of this ecosystem if you're
not familiar with all of this it's one
of the open source project that we
support at Anaconda it's a really nice
visualization tool if you haven't tried
it yet please feel free to try it out
and
to select part of the
data in the chart you can see it's
called linked selection the table and
the basic chart also get updated
and you can click on different
which is on the top to see different
data
the count of the
wind turbine farms and the capacity here
and you can Group by year or
manufacturer
so so that's the dashboard that I want
to show you
um
to make it happen so this is The
Notebook that I use to make this
dashboard right I'm going to go through
this code quickly with you so again we
load our data catalog as we have seen
before
and then we Access Data from the catalog
and get the wind turbine data frame as
appendix data frame
and then we can visualize this data
we have we Define two functions I'm just
going to go through this quickly if
you're interested to learn more please
visit uh panel panel docs to learn more
so here we have two functions where I
want to
get the the data set that I want to
visualize and I also want to get the
configurations of the visualization I
want to see in the visiting in a visual
charge because I want your bubble chart
that you have seen before and also I
want a bar chart so those are two
different configurations and my function
allowed me to choose between different
configurations
and as you can see from this app I have
a bunch of widgets on the top of my app
so
here is how I Define all my panel
widgets so you just do pm.widgets and
then select different widget types here
all of them are radio button group and
they can create different widgets
and then to create the video chart that
is
on the bottom here
uh okay
so you define your data your
configuration and different styles to
create a visual Visa chart as a pen
object
in order to find your data function and
your configuration function with the
widgets here so whenever you change the
widget on your chart on your dashboard
you want your visualization your
dashboard to to update by reflecting the
change in your widget so the way we do
that is that we use pn.bind to bind your
function this is a function again this
is also a function with the
corresponding panel widgets that we just
defined
so with this once and hold liable code
you are essentially writing your
function with all the widgets so any
updates on your widgets reflected on the
function you're calling
so that's how PM9 is working and then we
create the table that we're trying to
show here and then PM column is just we
want to create layout to lay everything
in column and and then you can Define
your layout in candle row which is
everything you know is grouped in a row
and then again another pin column is to
group everything in a column
any questions so far on panel and visit
the CEO of business right here this is
not an anaconda project but we love it
very much
yeah and I I have to mention that panel
doesn't only work with Mizzou we also
would work with our native attribute
plot it works with 4K works with
stepfather Plumbing any other
visualization Solutions so if you want
to use the panel to work work with your
preferred visualization package it's all
very easy and very possible
okay so uh to deploy this dashboard
I'm afraid to click this button but
let me not click that I'm going to just
show you what it looks like
um so here is a panel icon if you click
this button you can preview what your
dashboard looks like it's gonna be a
little big
um yeah so you can see the preview image
of your dashboard and you can make
changes in your preview will change
uh and then if you want to deploy your
dashboard that's
that's click on this button
button yeah it works
um and then this is the deployment
button where you can Define the title of
your app
test app you can give it a description
and you can publish your app
publish
how's it going
something warmer okay
sorry oh now it's published yay I'm glad
it didn't work went around
now we can click on this link okay it's
still being published
while we're waiting I want to show you
cool
it's working
yeah because I'm on the dev cluster for
this it's kind of slow for the moment we
can come back to that
um but if you want to see which app you
have deployed uh you can see all the
apps active apps here if you have any
active apps it will be here as well if
you click on
that's a little icon here you can
restart your dashboard deployment you'll
get unpublished you can get the links
you can do all sort of things
and now yay it's published I'm glad it
works
now you can share the stash board with
all your co-workers and whatever uh we
will add Access Control uh for you to
use this app within your company as well
for now uh where this is like everyone
has to see if you're typing this link
you will be able to see this dashboard
as well
Okay so
a final feature I want to show you is
really exciting
is
Anaconda assistant
okay
let's delete everything
here I'm just loading another data set
Bike Share data we have where we have
the date of the data and we have next
temperature of that day
and the number of rides of rice of Bike
Share at a certain date if we click on
this little button
assistant
um Anaconda system right now
automatically generate code to visualize
your canvas data frame we will add a lot
more features but here's a preview of
what we do you can select a data frame
to generate a graph let's
get the code
and see
what what it does
yay it's kind of generating a code for
us and it automatically runs all
Anaconda notebooks
what if we just want to please
only plot
and rice
okay now I have the plotting for number
rights
make the plot green
now we have a green plot
anything else you guys want to try
only plot 2017 data
now we have a clock for only 2017 data
so that is Anaconda notebooks
any questions
GitHub or some
how do you import them into this
yes that's a great question we'll have a
little uh icon thing
for you to click on your
GitHub page it's like Google Chrome if
you click a button it will automatically
open a Google Chrome Chrome uh um sorry
Google collab with Anaconda notebooks
we'll have the same thing when you click
a button on your Jupiter
uh on your GitHub page you'll
automatically open all your in other
books
yeah you can also just download
everything and upload just drag and drop
to your encounter
yeah so that's a great question
um
Okay so
I'm pretty excited about intercom
assistant and we have a great team of
people working actively to improve our
Anaconda system features please let us
know if you have any feedback we would
love to have
Okay so
yeah so we have gone through all those
exciting things about Anaconda notebooks
if you have any have any questions
please go to our
community.ana.cloud page
um you can ask questions there you can
showcase your the work there as well
yes so I think you've demonstrated like
a loading data but like I wonder if
already dealing with some of those data
persistent or
yeah for
we don't save any data anywhere we just
point to the URL of where the data is
saved but say if I'm like training and
then generating or like generating data
What's this called like what is that
yeah you can say that in your anaconda
notebook instance
like the way you save your data locally
alternatively you can point it to an F3
bucket to save your data there okay
gotcha
yeah thank you for the question
um and I just want to acknowledge all of
our co-workers who have worked really
hard on Anaconda notebooks is truly a
team effort and uh just let me think I
uh teammates who are working on this
project and I want you to thank you all
for being here and being so nicely
listen to my talk and please register
register at anaconda.cloud and the free
upgrade code is pi Seattle
enjoy
[Applause]